[Music]
welcome back to good day las vegas metro
sheriff joe lombardo joins us once again
for our morning cup of joe's segment
sheriff good to see you once again
good morning john all right so it's
still a few months off but
we look ahead to new year's eve as soon
as the one before has just finished and
here on the las vegas strip it's a big
deal of course
but we've got covet around we've had
some issues of
crime on the strip recently what are the
plans underway right now from metro
with regards to new year's eve in las
vegas
uh so in today's
timeline or today's schedule they are
planning fireworks
uh lbcva in las vegas events wants to
move forward with the fireworks show
now as far as the county issue and a
license
uh to block las vegas boulevard and for
customers pedestrians to occupy las
vegas boulevard
that is still up in the air so and
whether there's going to be any
uh live entertainment associated with
the event or not
that's still up in the air so we're
going week to week john
it's it's unfortunate but with the in
the
days of kovid and the unknowns
associated with colgate
we still don't know what that's going to
look like we'll switch gears a little
bit recently metro had a bit of a
graduation for communications
specialist trainees it's a 10-week
academy it's a
pretty intense talk about these uh these
employees now with metro what they do
and and just if it's a
need that you guys still need to fill
moving forward
yeah it's a it's a critical need that's
our first point of contact for our
citizens when they call
whether it's they're in distress or not
or whether it's a general call for
service
um but the important piece on that is
we're hiring and we've had continuing to
hire during this coveted
uh pandemic i have put a hiring freeze
on most of the specialties within the
police department to include police
officers
until we can figure out what the budget
looks like moving forward but
dispatch specialists that is one
specialty
or one classification we have continued
to hire
because of the important needs so it's a
10-week academy
they do a classroom environment and then
they do a live environment
out on the dispatch floor so the
qualifications are you got to have a
high school diploma
be able to type 35 words per minute and
have a good attitude obviously and pass
a background
i'm also curious what has retention been
like at metro we've heard in other parts
in other uh parts of our community that
retention in some
areas has been a bit challenging is
metro seeing the same thing
no i'm happy to say we're not seeing the
same thing we're seeing our normal
numbers of attrition
year over year currently there might be
a handful of people that have uh
decided to pursue a different career as
you know associated with what took with
uh the reforms and the defunding the
police conversations and dealing with
protesters
and people you know in that anger
interaction that they're they didn't
sign up for
uh but that's less than a handful of
people well sheriff thank you again for
joining us and taking our questions if
you at home have a question for sheriff
joe lombardo you can submit it at
eightnewsnow.com
find out if it's answered every
wednesday